this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status simple of choice
this is the ramsay show we help people
build wealth do work that they actually
love and create actual real amazing
relationships george campbell host of
the entree leadership podcast ramsey
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five george i am excited we
announced yesterday that we are doing a
free
live stream it's gonna be about an hour
long it's completely free and it's all
about well we're calling it the real
estate reality check i love that i had a
name that was not as good it was the
struggle is real estate
that one did not pass the marketing vibe
check unfortunately
yeah when you have to do a rim shot
after your marketing i don't know if you
have to go
right
come on guys for everybody to get what
you're saying then george it's a bad
slogan way better name reality check and
that's exactly what people need to do
yeah so this is going to be a lot of fun
you guys july the 14th rachel cruz
george campbell and i are going to jump
in front of the camera we're going to
spend an hour with you walking you
through facts
because here's what happens that's why
we call this reality check actually the
real estate the realty reality because
here's what happens nothing like there's
two things where people go completely
down
the rabbit hole like they're on lsd they
lose their minds and they make up these
stories in their heads
one of them is conspiracy theories
and one of them is real estate
i've been doing real estate since i was
18 years old so i've done i've had a
real estate license 42 years wow okay so
i've heard it all and the one that uh no
one gossips in america like they gossip
about what a piece of real estate sold
for they just make up crap
they just make it up they go well i
heard the neighbor
i heard the neighbor got two million
dollars for that i heard the neighbor
or i heard that i heard they knocked a
half a million dollars off the price
yeah but did you hear
that the entire garage had fallen in and
the septic system was bad did you hear
that part that there's a reason they
knocked it off it's not because the real
estate market is crashing that there's
actual facts and reasons and data under
this and did you i heard the neighbor
and when someone starts their real
estate diatribe narrative with i heard
the neighbor you're getting ready to
hear bad information that some goober
made up in the rumor mill and it's just
not true you need to actually check the
actual courthouse and see what the house
actually sold for oh my neighbor's
asking 2.5 million well hey so mine's up
for sale for 8 million i mean what that
doesn't mean anything goopers going to
pay that
what somebody's asking has nothing to do
with reality because there are some
people smoking drugs when they put their
house on the market and they decide to
ask that i you know i heard the
neighbors asking who what gives a crap
what you need to deal with is an actual
facts charts and graphs
that's what we're going to help you with
we're going to teach you where real
estate prices come from
is there going to be a housing crash
no there's not
spoiler alert
and i'm going to walk you through
exactly with actual math and data and
economics and like facts and stuff
instead of narrative and rumor i did not
and drama you were stirring up the pot
dave you just said hey the market's not
going to crash you would have thought i
mean people are up in arms about man you
piss people off when you come up against
their little conspiracy theories
but here's
well bent on the world coming to an end
i don't like it when someone says it's
not
yeah and i will give you facts and data
that i make up
from some conspiracy website because
let's just you know
100 of what you hear on the internet is
true abraham lincoln said that so there
you go
oh my gosh people seriously all right so
we're going to try some actual facts and
actual data we're going to teach you
about supply demand and how that works
we're going to teach you what recessions
and inflation and interest rates do to
real estate markets and we're going to
tell you exactly what's going on and
then you're gonna understand where the
real estate market is gonna go in the
next six months to two years and you're
gonna be able to make good like adult
decisions instead of like a screaming
beagle chasing a rabbit
some of you people lose your minds
calm down
you cannot think when you're panicking
i want to show them what to do when
you're greedy and when you're afraid you
make bad decisions yeah
and if you're whether you're looking to
buy or sell we're going to show you the
right steps to do it so that you don't
have buyers or more so that you don't
make a bad decision there's a right time
to do this financially yeah and there is
some things changing for sure
the market is definitely people are
seeing price cuts because it was
overpriced and now they're going dave
it's crashing i told you
there's a difference in price cuts on
unrealistic asking prices that's like
your crazy neighbor is asking too much
an actual value drop
okay the house is praised for this
and i you know it appraised for eight
hundred thousand but we put it on market
for a million thinking we were gonna get
just to see thinking we were gonna get
it market's hot because because we're
those people you know and now we've
realized the market's not gonna actually
sell for over appraisal and so we're
gonna reduce the price to appraisal and
now we call that a price cut
so so now you've got the house listed
for what it should have been listed in
the first place ladies and gentlemen
that is not a price cut
that is called a reality check
you dialed in and realized okay we're no
longer in the land of auctions and we're
actually going to sell a house so uh
because you know you put a house on the
market today you're not you may in some
areas get 83 offers over the weekend but
most of that's done
and if the only time you've existed in
the real estate market is when you put a
house on the market and it's you got 83
offers in 48 hours if you have existed
only in an unrealistic real estate
market that is that i've been doing this
42 years i've seen that happen for about
two years the last two
years prior to that i've never seen
people multiple offers on a single
property was very unusual prior to that
and 80 offers on one property in 48
hours was completely unheard of
completely unheard of so if that's your
only understanding in the real estate
market you don't know how the real
estate market works
you you know you were dealing in fantasy
land and so when things slow down it
feels like a crash it's not because it's
been on the market
a return to normalcy
which
i love it so real estate reality check
july the 14th uh we we're going to
continue to give you hints of what we're
going to say which is like common sense
and stuff kind of like we do around here
all the time we don't work in drama we
work in facts and we work in data and
all those kinds of stuff so yeah check
it out you can get a free pass to watch
this get your goober friend who thinks
the sky is falling if you if you know
chicken little personally invite them to
watch this okay
ramsey solutions dot com slash reality
check ramseysolutions.com reality check
it is a free live stream july the 14th
and if you disagree just hate watch it
that's the new thing dave on the
internet now you just watch it watch it
knowing you're gonna hate it and so you
just get riled up the whole time going
that dave ramsey telling me it's not
gonna crash i'll show him in the comment
section
yeah and there they are there you go
okay well i mean yeah you can do that if
you want to that's okay i don't care but
i i don't really expect to um convert
someone who's already
crazy um because you got friends you
know like rachel with the conspiracy
theories yeah you can't talk them out of
it no amount of facts
the number of facts doesn't matter okay
they're just they've just decided that
this is the way it is and they believe
this whole narrative this mythology and
so you presenting them with facts just
confuses them
and it doesn't convert them though it
doesn't make them come down off of their
crazy land that they're visiting and the
same thing's true here if you're just
hell bent and you're sure the economy is
going to crash and anybody that says
anything otherwise is crazy you can hate
watch this if you want to watch it but
you're wasting your time because i'm not
going to change and you're still going
to be wrong after you watch it so
there's that
so you know join us july 14th
we will get in your grill and tell you
how this is going to work good stuff
we're excited about it can you tell it's
all free by the way ramseysolutions.com
realitycheck if you don't like it we'll
give your money back
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
george camel ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five two two five
pam is in atlanta hi pam welcome to the
ramsey show
hey
how's everybody great how can we help
today
okay so um i am calling because my
husband and i
have finally decided that we need to um
we need to take care of our our
financial situation good um
about
three or four years ago
his aunt handed us the total money
makeover book and we
took it
um and we were like no we're okay we're
surviving used it for a question okay it
was a coast guard yeah yeah well then we
passed it along to another family member
and said oh you might need this more
than we do and
we're finally tired of
surviving we're we're tired of you know
the paycheck to paycheck and we have
everything we need
but i think she's ready george
that's the biggest step of all i'm proud
of
so well thank you give us a picture a
snapshot of your financial picture
what's your income and how much debt do
you guys have
okay so um
before taxes were right at 130 we bring
home 98.8 a year that's between the two
of us
um
debt is
about 76 000
also we have um we kind of built our
home um
well we didn't kind of we built our home
ourselves my husband really built it on
some family land
so
kind of like a barn dominium so we have
no mortgage
so all of that debt is credit card loans
and then two car payments
yeah so
we i have i have ordered the book i
ordered how can we best help you today
okay so i ordered the book from amazon
they sent me the wrong book
and i sent it back and now they're
supposedly sending me the right one
and i guess i just need
i need to hear
um i need you to tell me like just push
me in that direction um
i don't want to say i'm a skeptic but
you know i do a budget every quarter um
i used to do an annual budget and it
never worked it always fell apart it
doesn't work oh
yeah that's
sometimes there was some months at worst
and then some months it doesn't work
yeah
because every month is different
right and you're trying to operate off a
template
instead of instead of reality
this is correct and so it won't work
unless you do one before the month
begins each and every month because that
way you're customizing what my income is
that month i know exactly what it's
going to be for the coming month in
almost every case and i know exactly
what my expenses are going to be or a
really good accurate
uh projection of them and so you take
all of your income and you give every
one of those dollars a name a mission
before the month begins and here's the
hard part any goober can do that you can
do that on a yellow pad
okay it's sixth grade math third grade
math
all right but the trick is then to
actually use that through the whole
month
and not do anything with money except
what's on that paper
right and you and your husband pinky
swear and spit shake and agree to this
is a freaking contract
and so the way we always used to teach
in the old days in fpu and it still
applies today is
remember when you were a little kid i
was a little kid my little sister would
say you're not the boss of me
and that's the deal with the budget the
budget is not the boss of you
you get to tell the budget what it's
going to do
until the budget is done
and then the budget becomes the boss of
you
right but you're the boss of it until
it's down on that paper and then it's
telling you what to do so it's saying no
pizza tonight goober you're 76 000 in
debt stay at home and eat leftovers
that's the budget bossing you around but
if you're not looking at it and going
we're over we're about to go over on our
food budget you won't stay home you'll
look back at the end of the month and go
oh we went over on our budget again
budgets don't work no you didn't stick
to it budgets work if you stick to them
right but you can't do that on a
quarterly or annual basis it does not
work though
so okay that that that's the part of the
budget thing that works and then we're
going to show you the whole system
to get you completely out of debt
and become wealthy all the way through
spoiler alert but then the trick is you
got to do every one of the steps
okay and if you think we're wrong we're
not you are
we've shown 10 million people how to do
this i don't know anything about
anything but this stuff i got it dialed
in
and pam the average the average person
to do this stuff they'll get out of debt
within 18 to 24 months if they get on a
budget they get serious they start
making some sacrifices and based on the
numbers you laid out that's you guys you
can do this stuff and you've got money
coming out of your check for retirement
and and or big health insurance or
something else because you got too much
coming out of your check
yeah yeah it's um health insurance and
401k for months yeah so you're gonna
stop your 401k temporarily are you
getting a big tax refund too
um not big no usually between 12 and
1500. okay all right then that's only
100 a month too much is coming out of
your check for taxes
okay so we adjust that a little bit but
not much
and then we're just going to get on
beans and rice rice and beans because we
want to be out of debt more than we care
what somebody thinks and that might mean
selling a car it might mean not it will
mean not going on vacation or going out
to eat until you clean up this freaking
mess you made and then you're gonna be
free what would it be like to have no
payments in the world
that would be awesome now we our next
step after um
we would like to
either purchase or build a house like no
not now
not now you're broke no no after all of
this is done okay let's get out of that
first that's our goal yeah get out of
debt build your emergency fund and then
you can start piling up cash and build
you a house with cash
okay that sounds amazing because if you
don't make payments you're gonna have
this thing called money because you make
130 000 a year
right
okay so um
what do i need to do today until my book
gets here the correct book gets here
well here's what i want you to do you're
are you doing a budget on paper right
now excel what are you doing
on paper hand write it in paper have a
big yellow binder that stays on top of
the the book that's coming your way i'm
going to gift you ramsey plus that
includes every dollar premium and
financial peace university and so in the
meantime what i want you to do is start
your every dollar budget this is digital
it's going to be easier to track than
pen and paper and i think that's going
to do better for you and watch all the
videos in financial peace university on
top of that until the book gets there
the book is fantastic and it's
universal
financial peace university is better if
i could recommend one thing and you're
willing to do it that's those nine
lessons so tonight we're going to sign
you up tonight you and your husband
watch the first lesson
okay and download the every dollar app
and start your budget tonight on the
every dollar okay and the both of you
now you really have to be committed to
the vision of this
and it's a life change situation but
it's going to set you free if you do it
okay
because you got to get tired of being
tired
i am so tired of living like this
very much so yeah
hey you got this you can only places up
from here pam we're rooting for you hang
on we're gonna uh austin will pick up
and get you signed up you know i spoke
to a group the other day and um and i
got to listen to a group of uh guys and
gals that had come through a drug rehab
center
and what they said was um
four different ones got up and they've
been clean and dry for two three four
years got their life back you know got
got to see their children again their
children have been taken away from them
everything else these were hardcore drug
addicts uh crack heroin
you know everything and they were
completely dry and completely cleaned up
and i got to listen to them and then i
talked to them a little bit afterwards
and every one of them said and the guy
working the running the rehab center
said uh the people that get clean and
stay clean all share one thing they
always at some point say
i'm tired
i'm exhausted
i've been running from
these drugs
or to these drugs for so long
and the ones that are ready to change
say i'm tired so when someone says i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
like she said she's tired of this
that's always over that's a great
indicator no she's not doing heroin
that helps too but she's i mean the
point you're right but the point is that
that it's all behavior change and
behavior changes behavior change i mean
if you look down and you go i'm tired of
being fat you know i got you know i
looked down i'd gained a whole bunch of
weight eating donuts during covet and i
said i'm tired of being fat i'm tired
and i was physically tired too but
that's when life change starts there's
that but you can google how to get out
of debt but doing it's the hard part
yeah i mean everybody knows what to do
the knowledge is easier you lose weight
you eat less and you exercise more away
from the donuts ramsay get away from the
donuts boy i'll slap it out of your hand
if i see one all right i'll see how that
goes for me yeah see how that works out
for you this is the ramsey shop
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software
the faster you grow the more likely you
are to lose control of the numbers and
here's the reality if you don't know
your numbers you don't know your
business that's why we use netsuite by
oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today cj and jen are with us in
pittsburgh it says on my screen you guys
are debt-free congratulations
thank you very much well done how much
did you pay off
112 000 in 20 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
we started out about a hundred thousand
dollars and ended up about 125. cool
what do y'all do for a living
i'm a prison guard and i'm a pediatric
speech pathologist awesomeness very good
what kind of debt was the 112
our mortgage oh
talking to weird people
yes we are yeah normal's broke
the biggest compliment you can get
around here is when we call you weird
because normal's broke
normal sucks and you guys have your
mortgage paid for you're amazing what in
the world how old are you two
i am 43
and i'm
45. when'd you get married
2004.
okay so
18 years ago
yeah
sweet little cj and jen get married and
they're clueless
did you ever think you were gonna have a
paid for house in your 40s
none are 40s no but it feels amazing
yeah i mean you would have thought most
people think they're never going to get
paid for if they do it'd be like old
people stuff right
but you're in your 40s and you got it
paid off
what's it worth
um probably around 280 right now with
this crazy market i love it so cool this
crazy market you own a house
love it you're not worried about
interest rates
that's awesome
you got a better rate than anybody out
there that's got a mortgage i'm just
saying way to go you guys
that's amazing okay what started this
journey how did you guys get on this
ramsay stuff and got going 20 months ago
like everybody you know we had your book
and we read it and i was ready he wasn't
he was ready i wasn't and then
you know several years ago he came home
and said hey i heard on the radio that
fpu is going to be at a local church do
you want to go so
i called my mom and set up nine weeks of
babysitting and it was game on we paid
off genius 22 000 of school loans in
about six months and then just kept
following the plan
and then
like
almost two years ago the mortgage
statement came and
we looked down and we were had paid
about a hundred and twenty thousand
dollars but still owed 112 and our
original loan was we'd only paid like 60
000
of the actual principal and it just
set me off so i we have three girls and
we decided to make a
bowl of stones that were 500 each and
every time we paid 500 bucks we took a
stone out and our goal was to be done
before our oldest turn 16 and we
accomplished that goal in 20 months
instead of 24 so so you made it with
four months to spare
that's very cool that is very cool so
when you signed up for financial peace
university and you both and you got the
babysitting lined up and you both go
over there before you got to the first
class
who was already more on board than the
other one
i think at that time once i'm i read the
book but i need to hear it in person and
be with other people doing it so i think
as soon as we signed up for the class i
was
ready to go what about you cj i was
ready to go too okay wow so so it was my
job was easy once you got there
yeah you needed the social proof
of oh we're not alone always about money
but having that plan and just that first
class we came home and we're just
gung-ho ready to go yeah you can talk
about working out but when you hire a
trainer and join a gym
now you're committed
yep yep yeah that's it that's game on
wow you guys are fun that's great okay
you paid off your house you're 43 years
old 18 years into marriage you paid off
everything you did it four months early
tell people after going through
financial peace university what is the
main things they have to do if they want
to be like you when they grow up they
want to be debt-free what's how do you
get out of debt
you got to follow dave's plan you have
to budget and pay in cash and just
commit it and then we got we have three
girls and we got them all involved and
they were cheering us on and they were
you know picking the perfect stone every
month and
just
super encouraging so you just unity to
do it they also help to keep us in check
because there's times where they would
say that's not on the grocery list oh
they're calling you out
yeah they would take things out of my
hand and put it back on the shelf if it
wasn't on the list that was our little
list wow that's part of that we stayed
true to the list this kid this kid's
going to be a multi-millionaire not only
did her mom and dad set her up but uh
because they're dead free but now on top
of that she's actually had a model of a
person a grown person with self-control
and stuff
yeah wow and even i have to say we we
follow up until like two years ago we
were still sort of that davis with that
one credit card for gas and tires and
our middle one said to us if you pay it
off every month
and dave says don't have it why do you
have it and i said i don't know and she
goes can i cut it up
wow
look at each other and said sure so now
it's on our fridge and a shape of a
flower magnet because our at that time
11 year old said what are you doing
that's incredible i love this kid you
raised a good one
you're not raising weak women around
there i can tell you they're putting
stuff back on the shelf and cutting up
mom's credit card this is pretty cool
i like it good job you guys very very
very well done we're so proud of you
how's it feel to be a hundred percent
free
it's just a relief there's you know i
mean little things happen we were
actually supposed to be in person but my
husband had a little fender bender last
week and we stayed home to get the car
fixed and it's more of an inconvenience
there's just very little stress and it's
it's great
everybody needs to be debt-free
amen cj how you feel
uh i feel the same way especially with
prices of everything going up like
it's not
that it's not fun but it's not nearly as
stressful as what it would be if if we
had other things hanging over top of our
head yet hey man yeah amen you gave
yourself a raise not having that
mortgage payment yeah
way to go you guys we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you our latest
number one best seller
that's um going to be your destiny
that's the next chapter in your old
story for sure and i think these girls
are going to be deca millionaires
probably they worth 10 million
they're already working hard they
part-time jobs and making crafts and
selling cake balls and
wow
that's so cool got a copy of total money
makeover for you as well you can give
that away and get someone else's journey
started hopefully and since you've been
through financial peace university you
may want to give this away we're going
to give you a gift card for a financial
peace university membership for a year
and get you into ramsey plus you can
either go back through and watch the new
videos if you want they're brand new and
we just reset the whole curriculum it's
the best it's ever been or you can give
it away to somebody whatever you want to
do
cj and gin 112 000 paid off in 20 months
making 100 to 125
house and everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
all right girls three two one
[Music]
that is if you ever wonder what it
sounded like that's the sound of a
family tree being changed that's exactly
what the sound is picks are perfect you
hear those kids screaming the ones that
the one that cut up the credit card the
one that turned it into a flower the one
that put the stuff back on the shelf
screaming debt-free just four months
before she turned 16. see this is stuff
you remember and when she's an old lady
and she's talking to her grandkids she
got i remember back in all 22
momma and daddy paid off the house
that's before we had 250 million like we
do now kids
that's amazing that's what it's going to
be i'm telling you man this is how it
happens right here
man this is how it happened there were
so many components of that number one
they committed
they got the babysitting lined up then
they got around other people who were
doing it to encourage them and that
changed everything and they had visuals
they had the kids involved they were had
the rocks in the jar i love the rocks
they made it more visceral and so when
you do all those things you're bound to
become debt-free sooner rather than
later yeah there's too many things
barking at you you've got visuals and
everything in front of you and you've
got people around you and your family's
involved and
there's accountability and encouragement
built into that whole system and going
to going to financial peace university
you can do it online if you want we
don't care it's fine but it's more
powerful when you do it in person with a
bunch of other people who are having the
same fears
that you're having who text you and go
hey we missed you this week where were
you yeah we'd love to see you next week
you know it's that kind of stuff that
makes it yeah or something not even that
nice like get your butt back in class or
something that's if dave's texting you
that's the one you're gonna get yeah
i love it where the flip were you yeah
that's you know people used to cry when
i was a coordinator
and that's why he stopped ladies and
gentlemen
i'm not very good at it oh it's better
talk radio
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today our question today comes
from blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee that means even
if you mismeasure you pick the wrong
color they'll remake your blinds for
free free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more always use the
promo code
ramseyblinds.com a great american
company today's question comes from jill
in mississippi she says i'd like to hear
your opinion on an engaged christian
couple asking for donations via gofundme
to help them pay off the groom's debts
so they can start their marriage
debt-free
well i've heard it all dave that's an
interesting one
gofundme which if you don't know is a
fundraising platform online you can set
up for pretty much any need and people
can donate you can set your goal and you
get to keep all the money even if you
don't hit the goal with gofundme
so for an engaged christian couple
asking for donations to get this groom
debt free i love the heart behind it i
love that he wants to become debt free
that's about where i stop liking this
picture
it
you know what makes it feel weird is
just the gofundme part
that's the only thing that makes me
because listen if they just call if they
just said hey uh in lieu of wedding
gifts we'd like cash to pay off our debt
you wouldn't think that was weird no i
mean you would go that's oh well you
it's weird it's different but i mean you
wouldn't most people want to get
yourself that wouldn't be a turn-off
but for some reason it's a turn-off and
this woman thinks it is because she has
to throw in the christians which has
nothing to do with this
what is it what does
i don't know where that came out go fund
me is not in the bible i mean i don't
what is that
they're an engaged christian couple
which the i'm reading between the lines
this person doesn't think this is proper
she's trying to say it's not christian
it has nothing to do with a faith look
instead of wedding gifts they wanted
cash
that doesn't turn me off but when you go
go find me it kind of because i'm an old
geezer i just i'd immediately go there
but that's just a modern way of getting
cash instead of
it's a technological way of getting cash
when you take the wedding part out of it
it's like i have to venmo oh give me a
break but okay but
right um
there's no real need here now if they
were in turmoil there was a health issue
it's a little bit different but just the
fact that you're getting married doesn't
make me go well we should definitely pay
junior's credit cards off yeah but if i
mean when you get married you get a
whole bunch of crap
as gifts that you're never going to use
i'd rather have the cash personally and
get the debt paid off
i don't think it's tacky but that's me i
don't have any couth so i have no idea
i don't know which side the fork goes on
okay so what do i know but
coming from a modern millennial we had
our normal gift registry but we also had
a house down payment fund because we
were why is that not as tacky as this
because it was just a thing if you
wanted to support that instead of buying
us a spatula you could do that but it
wasn't asking me to pay off the debt
before the wedding via gofundme that had
nothing to do with the wedding so it
feels separate
i don't even know if anyone did it it
was just a fun thing we decided you know
this is what we're passionate about and
we're going to put it on there in case
family and friends yeah the question
actually i'm reading into it it does not
say this is instead of a wedding gift
this just starts it just says make
donations now that's different from
people who may not even be at the
wedding yeah that's different too no i'm
not gonna give somebody but in lieu of a
wedding gift if they would rather have
cash because they are trying to buy a
house
like george i would be cool with that
i'd rather have a house than a cake
knife
and that's the problem you go to target
and you start scanning things
willy-nilly because you think every
couple needs the cake stand stop buying
the cake stand millennials what are you
doing with the cake stand it's well and
worse than target home depot oh that's
dangerous for the game give george tools
that he doesn't even know what they do
well now they have the fancy battery
ones so i get more excited about that i
know but you don't still don't know what
they do they're just for battery okay
fair point so but i mean yeah that's you
could get you could get a bunch of crap
in our culture and money actually
translates so i don't know um
jill obviously thinks it's tacky and i
can tell that because she throws the
christian thing in there so i'm just
saying but um
i if it was a in lieu of a wedding gift
and it was cash it wouldn't feel as
weird but because we're not sure it's a
wedding gift and because go you threw
gofundme in there like you're some kind
of a charity
uh that's the part that makes it because
gofundme is almost usually for need well
someone
lost their house in a fire
medical bills because they got cancer or
something like that right and that's
usually the stuff go fund me just
getting married and you got some debt i
want to buy a new car i've got to go
fund me would you help me you know
people do that stuff there's some
goobers have it on there for paying off
their student loans and stuff and
people we see that stuff pop up but
that's all weird and maybe that's what's
weird about it i don't know well note to
self dave's not going to support my
gofundme so i won't ask no i really
won't i might give you some money but
it'd just be i'm not running through
that i'll tell you hey whatever you got
i'll take it yeah well yeah i've got a
battery-operated sawzall i'll just tell
you that all right open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
caleb is with us caleb's in detroit
michigan hey caleb how are you
good how are you better than i deserve
how can i help okay
um well before i get to my question i
just wanna say thank you for everything
you guys are doing i've been a long time
listener like even in high school i was
telling my friends sorry guys can't go
out to eat they've said no so
just appreciate you guys want to say
thank you before i get started thank you
how can we help
so um recently
over the last couple years i've been
working in the fast food industry and um
i've really taken a strong interest in
entrepreneurial roles and leadership
roles as well so i've been looking to
try and get into a franchise opportunity
i've been doing a lot of
networking if you want to call it that
my name's been passed around a couple
times and i have a couple opportunities
now in front of me and i'm a little
stressed about the decision that i need
to make between these two
so the first option would be um there's
a group of investors who have bought uh
three franchises and they need someone
to run them
so they've offered me a position as the
operator i would take a salary of a
livable wage and over the course of five
years i would build a sweat equity in
the business of
twelve and a half percent
if i wanted to buy and i could buy in
more and if i do well at it they'd be
willing to um let me operate more stores
and buy in for more as well as they do a
lot of real estate work that i could get
into
so lots of opportunity for growth if i
perform well
the other option was a um store that
basically i would be the franchise
partner and operator i would be
running the day-to-day operations there
would be no equity i would take
half of
profits
the store itself when looking over the
piano i should be making anywhere
between
120 and 150 000 a year so it would be
really good income um
but there's a no compete clause so i
wouldn't be able to um kind of expand
from there so we're looking at
taking a big cut um to start off with as
far as pay an opportunity to grow or a
substantial income
with not a ton of opportunity to grow
are there any startup costs with either
of these that you have to pay into
um the uh second option would be about a
ten thousand dollar buy-in um the first
option i would buy into what you don't
own anything
it would be more of a franchise uh fee i
know but you're
you're not going to be an owner in the
second option
correct yeah
so you're not buying in
right
now that's a bad structure
you're buying him but you don't own
anything yeah
who gets the 10 grand yeah
his partner who's he's putting it
towards the franchise fee
but he doesn't own anything
that would
yeah and what's the store worth or
what's it going to be worth when it's up
and running the second option
the second option um
they do
if the p l from before it was closed is
accurate to what it would be when it
opens up they were doing about
two million dollars in gross revenue um
making about
two hundred
two hundred two hundred fifty thousand
dollars uh profit
very sorry i'm sorry uh
a little bit more than that basically
when cut profits i would be making
between
120 and 150 000 240 to 300 profit if
you're standing in half okay so in the
second deal if you had 12 and a half
percent ownership
uh for your 10 000
that match the offer on the table for
the first deal
um it would be a better deal
okay wouldn't it mathematically
um but you need to limit that you need
to limit the non-compete to a territory
to a range of um
a distance
miles
and two years max because it's not
enforceable legally anyway
past that um
very difficult to stick a non-compete
past two years and very difficult in a
situation like yours to make it too many
miles away um if the second guy won't do
that i'd go with the first guy because
i'm not paying him ten thousand dollars
for nothing
i'm not doing that on principle
doesn't make sense
hey thanks for the call
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they really love and create actual
amazing relationships this is the ramsay
show george campbell ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we answer your
questions the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
allison is in anchorage alaska to start
off this hour hi allison how are you
hi i'm doing great thank you guys so
much for taking my call it's an honor
sure what's up
so i feel like my husband and i are
missing out on an investment opportunity
of owning a home
because our employer provides housing
so we're kind of at a loss you know goal
oriented in mind for saving our money
should we be saving
to buy a house should we pay cash for
that house
it'd be fine you need to be saving in
good mutual funds at a minimum or you
need to go buy a property so you're
participating in the real estate market
who's your what kind of employer what's
your husband do
he runs a lodging business
so we did purchase of 10 acres and it
was sixty thousand dollars we did ten
percent down we've got it down to forty
thousand
five hundred bucks a month
but it's interest free doesn't matter
get it paid for don't try and go ahead
and get it paid off pay it off yeah
okay at least then you're participating
in the real estate market because here's
the fear you sit in the lodge rent free
for 40 years
and think about what house prices were
40 years ago
the market just kills you right so you
want to be riding that wave up as a part
of your wealth building even if it's not
a property you live in so
uh the 10 acres was a good move and you
could add to that after you get the 10
acres paid off you could go buy a rental
house and pay it off
okay so you would accept that we could
go ahead and buy a rental property even
though it's not our main
dwelling it's our only mortgage we would
have do a 10 down well i don't like it i
i want you to pay cash for everything
because it's the shortest distance
between now and
getting out i mean you know you're
camping on that 10 000 or that 10 acres
over there like it's something fun just
because there's no interest on it you
still need to get that stinking thing
paid off so i don't like any of that but
but uh because the reason i like it is
it keeps you from getting rich not the
you pay pay other people all your money
so how quickly could you pay pay that
off and then save up and put even 20
down
on a property i could throw 30 at it
today and still have my three to six
month emergency fund so that would bring
us down to ten i can save
two grand a month so five months i could
have it paid off that's amazing and yeah
start the saving process over again free
up those payments yeah and then start
the savings process and let's either put
a large down payment or pay cash for the
rental there's no hurry the point is you
don't want to go decades and not on real
estate
correct correct that's the only thing i
don't want you to do and i wouldn't want
to do it and you know i run into this
with pastors and parsonages
they've been in one's church for 25
years and they've had the housing
furnished in the parsonage and then they
retire and now they're homeless
and uh so because they didn't have any
kind of game plan for the end of that
story and so you're very smart to be as
you said goal oriented and be ready for
the end of this story so
very very good
lincoln's with us in dayton ohio hey
lincoln what's up
hey dave thank you so much for all that
you guys do
i we've my wife and i i am 27 my wife's
24
and we have paid off about 30 000 worth
of debt since november right um but we
still have we still have 40 000 more and
she's actually going back to get her
masters in education
um
and she wants to um basically the main
premise of my question is my wife likes
to upgrade a lot of things very quickly
and she likes paying off debt but not to
the point where she doesn't get what she
wants and so it leads up to me having to
um having to say no to a lot of a lot of
decisions on things that she wants and i
feel like a parent in our marriage i
don't want to feel like a parent to my
wife
so i don't know if you have any insight
on that well i sense that you're you're
feeling some resentment towards her
because you don't want to baby her but i
want to have you look in the mirror and
go maybe i haven't done a good job
getting us on the same page
i mean is that not the problem you're
not on the same page when it comes to
what your goals are and then what our
actions are to get there
yeah that could definitely be a fair
point it's hard to get other people to
be excited
it's hard to get other people to be
excited about your goal this ain't her
goal it's your goal
yeah her goals upgrades that is fair
so george is right so i would i would
have a conversation with her and go hey
listen i know you want to do these
upgrades and i love that i want to do
that but i want to do it the right way
and i want us to get out of debt first
because this is how it's going to propel
us forward and get us there even faster
without any stress or anxiety and now
she goes oh he wants the same thing i
want now we can start moving in the same
direction
yeah that's good
and then uh she's also so she's going
back and getting her master's right now
in education um and why is she doing
that just curious what's the end goal of
getting the master's
she got a degree in hr and after a few
months she decided that she didn't like
her job in hr so then she
took a
she is basically an aide for a special
education room and but she decided
that's what she wants to do so she has
to get her teaching degree in order to
do that it was the same price to get her
masters as it was the undergrad
yeah
and so she's already quit her job
yeah that was about six months ago and
so it was taking less money and then
also adding on more debt and that
doesn't feel like we're moving towards
the same goal um so when george said
that i was like kind of iffy on it
because there are like other symptoms in
this uh scenario of
her wanting her not being all in for
the ramsay plan it's not the ramsay plan
dude
it's the lincoln and his wife plan
you gotta decide what that is
and so here's the thing okay
it this is not a this is not a um
financial questions more of a marriage
question but
the um the deal at our house is
that we both have to be in agreement
and we both have a vote
my vote's not bigger than hers her
vote's not bigger than mine
her dreams are not bigger than mine my
dreams are not bigger than hers we both
have to be in agreement before we make
major decisions
so you don't quit your job without both
of us talking about it
unless you're sexually assaulted at work
you know and then you can quit your job
and walk out and tell me about it right
but i mean just because you changed your
mind to 24 years old three months after
you got out of college that you didn't
like your job and your whole career path
and so you changed it and gonna go back
to school again to fix this oh brother
so no we don't do that stuff we don't we
don't upgrade in this we don't not do
this we don't go pay off big debts we
don't we don't make big decisions but
we're both together and that forces us
to back up from the actual decision
itself and say is this decision taking
us
the fastest possible way to our goal and
are we in agreement of our goal
and so sharon and i just don't make
decisions that way and so in your case
in other words she's got it shan's got a
veto card she goes i'm not going along
with this okay and we're not doing it
until we talk it through and we see
where it fits
and um
very seldom does she do that very seldom
does say no not going along with that i
don't agree with that
and that vetoes it it stops
and it's not you telling her what to do
or she telling you what to do but you
both have a vote you have the ability to
stop the train if the train's off the
tracks
and y'all aren't doing that she's just
doing whatever the flip she wants to do
and you feel bossy
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america a lot of people uh
hate the idea of looking at insurance
with our new five-day guide to insurance
george camel will lead you to have
confidence in your coverage it makes
learning about insurance quick practical
fun funny
laugh out loud you're gonna have a good
time for every every day for five days
ramsey personality george campbell
sitting next to me will walk you through
a new insurance topic unpacking
everything you need to know to get the
right coverage for you go to
ramseysolutions.com confidence and sign
up and you'll get confidence in your
coverage a five-day free
video set of videos to show you all
about insurance george this is working a
lot of people watch this i think they're
just hoping for a laugh and they might
learn about insurance along the way and
that was the goal if we can put laugh
out loud and insurance together that
would make history these don't usually
go in the same sentence no
solomon is with us in arizona hi solomon
how are you
good thanks dave for taking my call sure
what's up
um so i was calling i'm in uh baby step
two i have about 32 well me and my wife
have about 32
000 and baby step two um household
income we have about 80 to 82 000
um but my question is about our house
situation
so my wife um bought her house that we
live in um about seven years ago she was
in dire need
and she got into a rent-to-own
situation
and
we paid 6.75 a month
uh 180 goes towards the principal of the
house the 495 is considered rent
so what i'm wondering is they said we
could pay it off
you know we have mortgage or whatever
we could pay it off
and go through
like a single bank
or
do we just write it out as it is
okay what is what is the payoff on the
contract now
um
last i checked which was a couple years
ago it was 53 000. what's the house
worth
probably as it fits probably close to a
hundred
okay what's your household some work
done um 80 to 82.
okay
yeah i'd run down to the credit union
and just get a 50 000 loan
and put the house into your name
um the reason is hey you're going to
lose all this equity if you lose this
deal
and uh so the never do rent to own never
do a land contract or contract for deed
which is what this is okay
the reason is the house is not in your
name
if the current owner gets in trouble
you lose everything
and there's nothing you can do about it
so let's say let's say he was in a car
wreck and got sued
for 500 000 for wrongful death it goes
as a lien against his property this
property is not in your name it's in his
name
all right
you would literally lose all the actual
owner i think it goes i think a company
the company that we pay to i think they
buy these houses if that company gets in
trouble and has a lien put on sales you
would lose the house the point is you
are paying payments as if you own it
you're acting like you've got 50 000
worth of equity and the house is not in
your name right right you don't own it
very dangerous
now as far as like i like even though
i'm in you know
um baby step two my credit i have pretty
good credit
um as far as the store my wife doesn't
she doesn't have any debts or anything
the point is you're going to go down to
a local credit union anyway right and
they're going to look at the whole
situation they're going to look at the
fact that they're buying this house at
50 cents on the dollar because it's a
rent to own
right you're buying it for 50 000.
they're gonna get a 50 000 loan on a
hundred thousand dollar property that's
pretty safe for them
okay okay and they look at an 80 000
income
to pay a tiny little loan like this
i mean some people making 80 000 by 50
000 cars
i don't regularly do that yeah i don't
recommend that i i don't recommend that
but my point is is that you your income
is very large for this deal
wonderfully large okay and there's a 50
000 worth of equity protecting them so
credit union will make this loan
okay
yeah you guys need to go get this house
in your name even if you don't keep the
house even if you turn around and sell
it
right
because you're gonna you're you're in a
very precarious and dangerous situation
with the property not being in your name
now i know we normally don't recommend
you buy a house while you're in baby
step two while you're in debt but in
effect here you've already bought a
house you've just done it poorly and in
a sense we're refinancing in a sense
here yeah i'm seeing a lot of these pop
up now dave with this way the real
estate market's been there's a lot of
slick online companies that are saying
hey it's basically a rent to own
scenario so that you can get into this
house sooner because you don't have any
money never do that so i want to steer
people away from those i've been getting
messages going hey is this a good idea
no
don't do it quick answer no save up a
down payment to the capital no yeah oh
don't do it katie's in san francisco hi
katie how are you
hi good to be here thanks for taking my
call sure what's up
um so i followed you pretty closely
after i graduated college and i ended up
paying off all of my student loans
thank you i have a credit card um but no
credit card debt and i just feel like
now i've gotten this like quote big girl
job and i i've just had a hard time i
feel like i've hit a plateau after
paying off my debt of not being able to
i've saved up a thousand dollar
emergency fund but like i'll end up
spending it and i just feel like i've
hit a plateau where
i just can't save any money and i feel
like i'm spending all my money and i
just can't like get to the next step why
why hello why oh why um i'm not
budgeting
it's hard i guess i
um more money than you've ever had in
your life and you're broke
i know i'm very what are you spending
your money on katie where are the money
leaks happening
i mean you know in san francisco i'm
going out to eat
um experiences traveling could you go in
instead
could you have some friends over
yeah absolutely okay let's let's get
creative and let's see what that does
for a month see how much money you have
left over and how it makes you feel so
katie you're trading short-term
thrills
for your future
yes and it's scary because i'm living
paycheck to paycheck and i don't want to
do that yeah and and you realize that
and so
now you have to decide each time you get
ready to go out to eat or go on a trip
you have to go i just gave away a piece
of my future
and i just brought stress into my life
so is the joy of the going out to the
club tonight
with the girls
uh is that joy
as is that equal to or greater than the
amount of anxiety i'm gonna feel when i
wake up with a financial hangover
tomorrow
no
that's why you're calling it yeah that's
why you're calling and so but my point
is you've got to put that into a
day-by-day basis and quit doing some of
this stuff that you know you shouldn't
be doing
yeah i guess i i know i can do it
because i work so hard to pay off over
like ten thousand dollars in debt and
then i just lost all
kind of i don't know i was like on a i
was born you got you got a great income
for the first time you're making more
money you've ever made in your life
and so you know it's like you got
lottery itis like you hit the lottery or
something
right okay here's what i'll do to help
you build that muscle i'm gonna gift you
financial peace university and i'm gonna
want you to do two very specific things
watch lesson one which is on budgeting
and baby step one with rachel and watch
lesson five with dr john daloni and i on
wise spending i think those two things
combined will give you some tools in
your toolbelt to go all right i'm gonna
walk through the framework i'm gonna
walk through this process i'm gonna
commit to the plan and just do it for a
month and if you do that and you hate it
you can go back to the way you were
living but i think you're going to feel
that sense of relief and you go i'm in
control i'm confident in my money
decisions i can do this you got to ask
yourself how old are you
i'm 24. yeah so you gotta ask yourself
what the 34 year old katie is she happy
with what you just did
totally she's gonna be pissed
right you're so mad that's what you're
saying you're so lame you're not fun you
used to be fun
i don't want to keep living paycheck to
paycheck and i just i know that this
like method works because i feel like i
got with gazelle like intensity to that
stuff and now i'm just and i want to
continue going
and i'm going to be real harsh now are
you ready
yeah i'm ready you need some new friends
okay
all your friends do is what you're doing
you don't have anybody in your life
that's like a grown-up oh you got party
girls in your life
you need some new friends
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage philip
and maria are with us hey guys how are
you hey dave hi dave welcome where do
you guys live we live here in nashville
we live in bellevue just up the street
all right very fun very fun how much
debt have you paid off we've paid off
fifty seven thousand dollars all right
how long has that been two years two
years all right and your range of income
during that time uh we were making uh
ninety thousand and started out making
ninety thousand and now we make 150.
good for you what do you guys do for a
living um i am a mortgage loan processor
and i'm a front-end developer all right
very very good what kind of that was a
57 000
it was a range of everything most of it
was student loans we had credit card
debt we had some personal loans from the
cars that we owned
and yeah just a little bit of everything
you guys are kind of normal yeah yeah so
what happened two years ago what was the
wake up call how'd you get tied into
ramsey stuff that's a good question it
actually kind of starts back in 2018
when we first kind of got into
everything yeah i had a medical
emergency that landed me in the hospital
and
it was a three-day stay ouck
um it's still kind of a mystery we don't
exactly know what happened but um
we moved to nashville shortly thereafter
and we got one of those
insurance letters that says this is not
a pill
and it told us how much that hospital
visit caused us yes and we had just
shortly before i ended up in the
hospital we had gotten on insurance oh
wow um and so
i kind of had a moment in our kitchen
um
when i realized where we would have
stood had we not
had the insurance
um and that was my
i'm sick and tired of being sick and
tired moment
and um
so it's a helpful couple of things for
us um our debt journey and as well as um
finding a new career path for me
um which was kind of what brought us
down to nashville we had lived up in
bowling green kentucky before then
and i moved down here in the summer of
2018
trying to find her a new career path and
just to try and get us a bigger shovel
to really get out of this because um
back before we moved down here we were
just barely making over 50 000 a year
between the both of us so we were really
just trying to to make a bigger shovel
to really get rid of all this debt cool
so very cool how did you guys get tied
in to us
um her parents yeah so really really
were helpful with that i've probably
listened to your show on and off um you
know since i was a kid and my dad did
his own version of
the ramsey plan
and
he gave me
financial peace when i graduated high
school
i read it and then promptly did not do
anything that it said i needed to do
and
then when
we had moved to nashville you were on
the radio you were on youtube you were
on podcasts and um i started listening
again
and
we got gifted total money makeover yeah
her mom bought that for her birthday
present year financial pieces university
financial pieces so someone gifted us
total money makeover i read it to him in
the car on a road trip that we took
shortly thereafter so i forced him to
read it you read it out loud i did yeah
she was a trooper you didn't even
audiobook no
the wife version of the audiobook yes
um and color commentary probably
uh and then i asked for fpu for my
birthday that year oh wow made him
watch all of them with me i was like no
we're doing this yeah yeah it was great
the the videos were were a great help
and um
i think what really helped us the most
was um the budgeting app yes and getting
that connected with our uh checking
account and just allowing us to have
that uh financial budget conversation
you know every month it just made it so
much easier to be able to do that
and that was kind of the biggest lesson
i think that we've learned is just being
able to get on top
and get on top of that that's awesome so
you got to tell us about the poster
holding there's a lot going on there are
you a science teacher what's happening
that's a great question so he's a really
big settlers of catan fan and
i wanted to make up some sort of
tracking for our debt and to motivate
him you want if i put this in his world
he's more likely to do it yeah right on
the fridge is where this is so it sat on
our fridge for a really long time um but
we got most of the way through tracking
everything and we realized that
since about 2017 my mom had been making
payments on my school loans and had
covered like a huge chunk of
um
what we would have what we had thought
we were going to be taking on and um so
we're very thankful to her mom
fantastically thankful for mom
and um it actually
um was one of several things that
encouraged us we have a few friends
michael and emily hi guys
um who had also paid off their debt
around the same time that we started our
journey and um
so we had a huge amount of support
and um
you know that just sort of added fuel to
the fire kept us going just kind of made
a game out of it
yeah like our last dead free screen you
have the visuals you got the social
proof from other people doing it you
have the commitment you've got the
parents you've known this stuff your
whole life and you went i'm sick and
tired and i think i know a guy who's got
a plan yes and you did it i'm proud of
you guys and if i don't dad or mom is
going to remind me soon they're going to
give me i love them they're going to
keep gifting me the book until i know
they were standing in the background
they kept tossing stuff in
until somebody finally picked it up
that's great one of the biggest
motivators was you know we would really
like to start having a family soon and
we actually just bought a house
yesterday and wow
so we've been able to make all of these
financial
decisions because we've been able to pay
off all of our debts very cool it's been
really cool by the way that's her
parents uh decision too that's their
motivator was for you to have yours yeah
she has she has said that
if you'll read this book i can have some
grandkids
i'll tear your motives
i love it
you guys are awesome man way to go i'm
so proud of you thank you how's it feel
to be free
oh it's still kind of surreal it feels
great but yeah it still feels surreal
before you ever go back
oh never never helped in fact i
gleefully um rip apart you know the
credit card envelopes that they send you
in the mail i'm like haha yeah it's
almost like a weekly ritual
just throwing out the junk mail i love
it
i love it i just you can put some
you know rip up the parts and put it
back in the prepaid envelope and send it
back to them
they get hit with the charges
that's right
let's stick it to the man way to go you
guys way to go we got a copy of baby
steps millionaires for you that is the
next chapter in your story for sure
and uh also a financial peace university
subscription obviously you've already
been through it um but the brand new
videos are out and the whole new class
is there you need to go through it again
or you can give it to somebody and pay
it forward and we'll give you a total
money makeover book which you for sure
can pay forward to somebody and i get
get them started on their journey i'm so
proud of you guys very very very well
done your heroes thank you thank you
yeah you are victory uh vic victor's
instead of victims we've got too many
people in this culture walking around
hoping somebody else is going to take
care of them and you guys decide we're
going to take care of ourselves yeah
yeah so very very good and you had a lot
of help a lot of encouragement which is
the way it should be
all right it's phillip and maria from
nashville 57 000 paid off in two years
making 90 to 150 count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream three two one
we're debt-free
[Applause]
oh that's how it's done right there
mom and dad's got to be proud too oh
yeah
it's every parent's dream yeah very cool
very very well done that's how it's done
boys and girls
you know you make a list you check it
twice
i don't care whether you have a poster
board uh with cymbals all over it or
whether you have rocks in a jar
uh bats in your belfry i don't care what
it is there's all kinds of ways to do
this you do you you as long as it causes
you to do this stuff that's what makes
it worth it and there you know there the
number of times we hear
uh
someone doing their debt free scream had
some kind of visual in their life it's
not that unusual we have them actually
on our website you can print off for
free all kinds of pdf stuff and people
want to do uh just because it's
i mean they do
links of
uh construction paper chains uh worth a
thousand dollars a piece all kinds of
stuff and we see it all the time you
talk about goal setting writing it down
on paper and this is a way to do that
you know what
normal people don't do that stuff they
think it's lame normal people are broke
it'll be normal go get you some
construction paper set you off on a
journey normal sucks don't be normal
be not conformed to this world but be
transformed
by the renewing of your mind
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today olivia is in panama city
hi olivia how are you
hey dave hey george i'm good how are you
doing today great how can we help
so i have a quick question for you i
have just got into car sales um so i
make commission here with my dealership
but then also the manufacturer that i
sell the cars for they pay us monthly uh
like a bonus but it's not taxed so i'm
trying to figure out when i found my
taxes next year how do you recommend
that i save a percentage of this money
or a month or an amount that i set aside
every month so that i'm prepared when i
go to file my taxes
25 of it
every time you get a check put 25 of it
in savings
okay what are you making what's your
income
uh well i have a guaranteed of 1 000. i
mean what's your total income going to
be this year
i i don't know it's 52 000 and then any
commission over that what do you think
you're going to make next month
200 what are you going to make
maybe 75. okay all right 25 percent of
work then
yeah okay and so um
because what it amounts to is you're not
employed by them it is taxable income it
has just not got taxes withheld because
you're not on their payroll so you're an
independent subcontractor for them
technically it's like a freelance job
right and so it is taxable and it'll be
taxed also with self-employment income
as well so um you're gonna get hit you
know 15.3 on that and about another 10
on your taxes so about a fourth of it so
you get a check for a thousand dollars
set 250 aside into a bank into a savings
account and then you'll be ready to file
your taxes and not be behind you it
should cover you
okay sounds good thank you so much i
appreciate your help thanks for the call
and george that'll work for a lot of
people doing the side hustles uh the
beauty of side hustles is you can make a
lot of money the downside is a lot of
people don't set their tax money aside
and they get in trouble it looks great
on paper you go i'm making good money
and then you forget about
self-employment tax you forget about the
you know quarterly estimated taxes
that's an important thing to keep track
of as well be filing that with the irs
if you've got a freelance job like that
yeah if you've done it more than one
year and you don't file quarterly
estimates you're going to get penalized
we don't like that so it sounds like
that was her first year on this that's
why i didn't push her on that but the um
you do need to set aside once a quarter
and a quarterly estimate's not hard to
file it's a little one-page document
it's basically got what you made
and any minus any expenses you have
creates your taxable business expenses
that you have for that business and in
her case she doesn't have any yeah so
i'm just saying
so then you're supposed to file that
quarterly estimate of taxes uh as if
you're withholding on yourself in other
words once a quarter and that'll keep
you from being penalized if you've done
it for more than one year but you you
folks are making a lot of money on your
side hustles you're gonna get yourself
in trouble with taxes if you're not
setting the money aside because you're
gonna get this big tax bill and you know
i made forty thousand dollars but now i
got a ten thousand dollar tax bill yeah
that'll bite you see and set you back
and you'll be in trouble uh and so
you've got to be very disciplined and
very careful and very self-controlled
with that it'll jump up and get you
david is with us david's in fort
lauderdale hi david how are you
hi dave hi george great to be talking to
you guys you too what's up
uh so i just moved to fort lauderdale
from oregon two months ago i sold my
house in oregon
uh walked away with 240 000. wow
yeah yeah it really started booming
um central oregon um
so with that money i put ten thousand in
my emergency fund
i paid off about ten thousand dollars of
debt i've been investing into a roth ira
now for several years and
putting in money into uh separate mutual
funds
uh right now in florida i'm going to be
starting a fire academy here in three
weeks about three months full time
academy
so my question is i'm going to have
about 220 000 left over i plan to live
off of
uh 20 000
of it during this three month academy
and uh my question is what to do with
the other 200 000 and bouncing back and
forth between i know um
high yield savings are about one percent
now they might be going up whereas
etf mutual funds are
you know annually or ten percent
although they're down now but
um if i plan to park it for about one to
two years
um
until i find where i'm gonna live where
i'm gonna work
and uh rent
for a couple years so let me get this
clear david you don't have any more debt
no no more debt okay no more debt and
that emergency fund is that fully funded
three to six months of expenses for you
yes yes yeah put ten thousand in there
which is should yeah i believe is enough
yeah if it's one or two years i'm not
risking it in the market that's too
short of a time horizon for me so i know
it's not exciting but that high yield
savings account is going to be your best
bet for a short time frame like that so
you can protect it
if you put 200 000 in to like a an index
fund to park it for two years
and it goes down 10 that's 20 thousand
dollars
that's a lot of money isn't it yeah i
mean i well i guess my thought was with
the prediction being you know wait two
years and it bounces back i i think the
market will bounce back inside the two
years but my but george's point is you
you know are you in a position to lose
20 000 bucks
i would i wouldn't like to know
you could do it i mean you'd still have
180
it wouldn't kill you but that's what's
that's basically about what's at risk
the chance of you losing more than that
historically would be very low
and you might make 20.
instead of lose 20. so that's possible
but the anxiety in between of watching
it go up and down may so may spook you
you know i think
i personally think the market's on sale
and i think two years from now it's
going to be back roaring again all the
data tells us that about bear markets
we're definitely in a bear market
uh by by definition it's a bear market
and so um you know do you the question
is do you want to ride that bear out and
buy while it's low and take that chance
and the chance i think you're what
you're doing is you're you're not
risking 200 000 you're probably risking
20 grand and if you want to take that
risk you could go to uh
you know uh just
an s p 500
a a simple
you know a simple mutual fund a simple
no load mutual fund
um or
uh you know if you if you don't want to
take that risk you would go to
uh high yield savings and money market
or you could split it you could put 100
in each yeah
take a little
with some of it a little bit of the
roller coaster ride and then some of
it's sitting there safe
um but uh you need to really think that
through but i wouldn't do anything other
than that with it just something very
very simple both of those in the
spectrum of overall risk is fairly low
you know versus putting it in something
like bitcoin where you could lose it all
okay
um and
very well may in the next two years so
that's a distinct possibility the way
the thing's dropping right now so hey
thanks for the call hannah's in dayton
ohio hi hannah how are you
i'm good dave
um
i have a question prepared for you
um so how can i get out of debt faster
i have about
um
about 53 000 in student loan debt
i have a forty five hundred dollar a
month car team or forty five hundred
balance on my car
and credit cards is forty seven oh five
and twenty three cents
what's your income
per month
is about
seventeen hundred dollars
a month
how old are you
29. okay what do you do for a living
i work for goodwill i am the job coach
for goodwill thus full time
that's interesting because you need a
new job
yeah you're starving to death
i am
i am this is a great market for you to
get a new job
okay and maybe two new jobs
i also own a business
what does that make i own
last year
um i made well i grew up so i brought
home ten thousand dollars
which is a huge growth i've been i've
had the business for three years um
and so this year's been the best year
i've had and i want to keep growing the
business yeah that's wonderful but
you're 29 years old and your total
income is under 30 000
so i really want you to i'm gonna send
you a copy of ken coleman's book
and uh from paycheck to purpose i want
you to really think about the career
side of this equation
and we'll also send you a copy total
money makeover to teach you how to work
the debt snowball but you need a bigger
shovel because the size of the hole
you're in versus a shovel you got is
troubling mathematically
i want you get your income up kiddo hang
on we'll help you with that
[Music]
dave here you can find all of our shows
with the ramsey network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the ramsey network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
it's a free call at triple eight eight
two five five two five nick is with us
in louisville kentucky hi nick welcome
to the ramsey show
hello how are y'all doing today great
man what's up
um me and my wife are currently
not in love with our current home uh the
market's pretty hot
uh we have talked about you know we're
working on some of our baby steps as in
paying things down
our income for the household is 145
thousand a year
we have roughly thirty six thousand
dollars in student loan debt so it's
still outstanding in roughly fourteen
thousand five hundred dollars
uh in unsecured or credit card type debt
um if we were to sell our home
we would net based off the market in our
neighborhood uh anywhere between one and
125 thousand dollars
would you recommend that we
continue down the baby step process and
pay that down and stay where we are in a
home we don't love
or potentially get it ready put it on
the market pocket the money rent for a
while and be completely debt free
going into a new home
how much do you owe on your cars
uh nothing we don't know anything on any
of our cars okay good
all right so you got one you're getting
120 out of truck you get 120 out you got
to put 50 down
in debt and
that frees you up an emergency fund plus
a small down payment on the next house
correct yeah
i'm doing that sure
okay because
given the market you know we had planned
on renting we are okay with that
obviously we don't really owe a whole
lot on i wouldn't rent long because i
don't think this market i i i'm not in
agreement the real estate prices are
going to go down
we're actually doing a real estate
reality check on july 14th that folks is
the 14th or 3rd yeah 14th that they need
to tune into it's a free stream on we're
going to go over the data with everybody
and show them how and where it's going
but i don't think the market's going to
shoot up either
i think it's right we're projecting a
five percent uh growth in real estate
prices this year
it was seven percent last year 18 the
year before 32 the year before
so um that's the actual data not not
people's feelings
and uh you watch the news too much you
lose your mind
so anyway absolutely the uh anyway i i
think renting for a year you're gonna be
perfectly safe i don't think you're
gonna see a huge increase i don't think
you're gonna see a decrease in prices
you may see interest rates tick up some
more
as uh the fed keeps screwing with this
under biden
uh because this binding administration
is just bound and determined to script
this economy they are messing with every
lever they shouldn't be messing with
from labor to energy
uh everything so you could see higher
interest rates but even then you go buy
a house and when rates if rates come
back down you just refinance
so i i would do this and go rent for one
year that'd be my plan
all right that's the reassurance that i
thought i needed yeah i would not do
that if you love the house you're in
correct and that is our problem is we do
we do not love it but we love the area
so we're willing to flex and
hang out for a year or so exactly sharon
and i did the exact same thing we had
kids in a private school because we're
in a crummy school district
we sold the house and rented for two
years
and uh put the kids in you know moved
into a great school district uh
this area that we live in today
and um
as i saved you know
back in the day you know twenty thousand
dollars a year wow it's a lot of money
back then yeah and um
and we were renting cheaper and we had
all the equity from the house we had
sold and we cleaned up the last little
bit of debt from the irs and other stuff
from the bankruptcy we'd gone through a
few years before
and uh so we were clean slate firmer
foundation for a foundation yeah and got
settled in the neighborhood the area of
town that we wanted to be in the county
that we wanted to be in and that kind of
thing um and then from there we saved
and bought the first house during that
two years there was a repurchase it
wasn't our first home it was our third
home but still and for a lot of people
selling their house right now to clean
up a mess could be a good thing but if
you gotta you make 145 grand and you've
got 50 grand in debt you can pay that
off there's no reason to sell the house
just because of that exactly there's the
math is not demanding you sell the house
but you're going to sell it anyway
because you don't like it exactly and
this is a good thing it feels like a get
out of jail free card so my caution to
nick is that you got to change your
behavior we got to actually decide we're
never touching debt again we've got
that's a really good point sometimes it
feels like oh we just got out because of
the equity in the house and appreciation
we can just keep living how we've been
living yeah you don't do this every time
to clean up your mess because you keep
making messes that's a good do it the
right way very good point patrice
patrice is with us
in detroit hi patrice how are you
hi dave it's an honor to speak with you
you too what's up um
okay well i have a distrust issue with
my
so-called financial advisor
when the market was up to 36 000 she and
i had our six months
routine call and she had someone else on
the line but she did let me know and
what she was doing was without me
realizing it at that time was trying to
start i guess get him started with new
accounts
and advise me to take some of the money
that i had been saving for my down
payment toward getting into a home
and put it into investments well i
already have a 401k rollover with them
so
i feel like i was number one misadvised
and i'm not happy about it and i'm
looking to just move on before q3 rolls
around and i don't want to pay fees to
this firm and yet another firm i just
don't i don't trust them now
what do you advise me to do
i think i don't think you should ever
work with somebody you don't trust
especially on money so you need to move
it but then let me scold you also
you're you're like a grown woman and
stuff
you made the decision
i know i own that so you know you didn't
you blame them
um
and so you get you know the trust factor
has to come down to you
so we teach people not to use financial
advisors as babysitters but instead to
use them as teachers
and so from now on the next time this
comes up your financial advisor's job is
to teach you and say you know if it was
me here's what i would do and why
and then based on that you
make your decision
and then it's your fault
okay
so you need to understand why they're
telling you to do this and then do it or
don't do it based on the why because you
have been taught and your incorrect
knowledge has increased and then you
decide when you're going to do it so
like patrice when i'm talking to these
nfl guys these little 23 year olds
and 24 year olds and they got 10 million
dollar signing bonus and they say i got
me a guy
that's somebody who's getting ready to
lose all their money
because some guy is going to tell them
what to do and they don't have a they
don't know their they you know they
don't know their butt from a hole in the
ground they're stuck and so they've got
it you have to go learn
you are in charge of your money
you have to take care of your money but
i would move it because i don't trust
him and then i would get an advisor in
my corner and i'm not going to have an
argument
with my financial advisor because they
don't they're not in charge of my money
i'm in charge of my money their job is
to teach me
and then based on that knowledge do i
believe the knowledge and am i going to
buy it and then based on that am i going
to make a move
that's what you've got to get there but
you can't you can't you can't ever look
back on them again and say it was their
fault because from now on it's your
fault
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today you know one thing about
doing these live events again there's a
lot of energy in the room when you get a
you know a room of 3 000 or 8 000 people
full of you know a theater an arena full
of people wanting to change their lives
it bleeds over on you
and you leave their you know you go like
a football game or a basketball game or
something you get excited it's fun your
team wins your team loses or whatever
and you leave and you're kind of excited
for those guys that just did their job
but when you leave and the you're
excited because you're like ready to go
do something for you
that's a whole different thing so that's
what smart conference is it's a day-long
event it is going to be october the 22nd
in dallas it is not yet sold out but you
can still get passes they're only 39 for
the whole day it's all the ramsey
personalities plus craig and amy
groschel from life church are coming to
speak on marriage so we'll be speaking
on mental health and wellness we'll be
speaking on careers leadership uh
marriage money millionaires christina
ellis ken coleman george campbell dr
john deloney rachel cruz craig and amy
groschel uh and dave ramsey it's gonna
be a full day
and you will leave smarter it's the
smart conference you're cooking things
up dave we've been having some meetings
about this we've got some surprises for
you oh yeah there we go so worth it it's
very entertaining it's probably our most
entertaining event it's on top of the
contest it is an absolutely phenomenal
live music you name it it's a great
event it's an immersive thing yeah
ramsey solutions dot com slash events to
get your whole 39 dollar ticket we ought
to charge 390 but we don't we charge
339. all right avery's with us in
hartford connecticut hi avery what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
how can we help
hey uh yeah so question i'm wondering if
i'm being too gazelle in time
okay
why
so last august i had uh finally gotten
to the point where i saved up a large
chunk of of money
and um i i bought my first house
i did a 15 year
and um i saved up i put down about 25
down
and um i saw everything would be fine
and dandy and i'd be able to calm down
at work with the overtime
and uh it was it was pretty
instantaneous that uh i went from uh
sleeping okay at night not sleeping and
not sleeping great at night why um the i
i don't feel i don't feel great knowing
that i that i owe somebody 180 190 000
oh okay
i mean but you the payment is is it a
fourth of your take-home pay
yeah yeah i can afford the payment no
problem okay um so what are you
why are you why are you freaking out
then
you're paying rent before and weren't
awake at night
yeah yup yup that's true
um
but i guess just just having my name on
on a loan for 180 thousand dollars
it troubles me and um i'm a worker and
i'm working right now i'm working
90 100 hour weeks and i'm doing it just
fine i'm half i'm happy i'm healthy i'm
just wondering if i'm being too gazelle
in 10. um and these are consistent 90
100 weeks
well what are you doing this for are you
trying to pay down the house early
what's your goal yeah every every yup
yup after uh after the budget is made
and after all you know all the bills
updated are you single every extra cent
yeah single okay
well what's your goal to pay this off
how fast you want to do it
the the extreme goal is three years the
uh the more realistic goal is five years
okay well do you think you'll burn out
doing this for three years straight
working 100 hours a week
i've been doing it for two and a half
years and i haven't burnt out yet
dude you're like an energizer bunny i
mean that's impressive i mean you're
telling us you're happy and healthy so
there's here's the thing we say to go
from intense to intentional once you're
in baby steps four five six which you
are correct
yes sir and me and my wife we decided to
be intense to pay off our house early we
did it in 26 months which
it sounds crazy and we did go really
hard but we also weren't losing sleep at
night
we weren't you know there was an
excitement we were intense about it but
it wasn't consuming our life either and
so i want you to have some balance there
i love that you want to pay this off if
you don't like debt great goal to have
but when it's consuming you're living in
your hen rent free it's not worth it
yeah if you're not sleeping and you're
working this hard out of some kind of
fear or desperation
that's not good for you
because the numbers don't indicate that
there's an emergency
there no there is no emergency i know
what you're acting like i have a very
healthy fund yeah acting like i have a
very
yeah you're a driven dude clearly no no
no no no you're you're spun up
like a saber-toothed tiger's chasing you
yeah i feel that way yeah
that's not okay
all right being intense and working hard
is okay
but being freaked out
as your reason for being intense and
working hard is not gonna be good for
you
you need to be able to shift gears and
go i'm gonna be peaceful
and ambitious
i mean there's times right now and i'm
i'm worth several hundred million
dollars that i work 100 hour weeks
it's just because i want to
because i'm enjoying what i'm doing
and i'm not doing it out of fear or
desperation or terror or i'm not spun up
when i'm doing it i'm doing it because
it's a goal and i'm ambitious and i
enjoy hitting the goal and usually when
i'm doing it i'm helping thousands if
not hundreds of thousands of people
during that week when i'm doing that
like when we do this real estate reality
check that'll be a 16-hour day that day
when i work that day on the 14th coming
up and so but um and i don't need to
work financially but i'm but there's a
different thing happening in my heart
i'm doing that to help other people
because there's so many people scared
right now
about real estate they're freaked out
and so i want to help and i want you
kind of coming at this
we're i don't mind the hours
george is exactly right i think your
hours are fine there's if you want to
work like a crazy man i do that
sometimes
um but i don't want you to do it from
desperation because you're not living in
an emergency avery
if you were i would tell you
and i would tell you to work like this
if you called me up and said i'm working
like this to get rid of my student loan
debt and i'm freaked out about it i'd
say okay stay freaked out get student
loan debt knocked out cause you got that
thing hanging around your neck but this
is a mortgage that you're gonna have
done in three to five years
and
there's no reason to freak out you're
still a young guy man you got time
you're doing really really really well
and so i would just breathe in and kind
of enjoy where you are
and then put your shoulder back into it
you know
smack them again baby get it done
i love that you're getting that done i
just don't want you to be afraid because
you don't need to be and having that
kind of anxiety is not a picture of
health to me so i want you to kind of
pan back and go where is this coming
from
and let's figure that part out and i
think that will help you navigate what's
next well
and the interesting thing is avery it's
like a lot of things
what you're doing is so smart
um
and it's easy for us to encourage you in
it but we want to be careful and say uh
abundant what's really going on and what
is it you're really running from or
running towards and so
let's get all that stuff straightened
out in your head make sure you make sure
you take sundays off let's put a sabbath
in there
make sure you're a church
make sure you're spending some money and
enjoying some of it and giving some of
it
go for a hike in the mountains
sit on the edge of a bluff and look out
over a valley
it's okay you're doing good man and then
go back to work monday
but you need to get a rhythm in here
that's got some peace in the rhythm
that's why you got a lake house dave
i turned down that street my blood
pressure goes down man i'm just saying
as soon as as soon as i turn on that
road it's downhill the last half mile
you you just put you could put up one of
those little
things on your on your arm and it'd be
just dropping right there
so dave you go real hard i mean we you
hold this to a high standard because you
go hard but we're also able to unplug
you the the thing the the point is is
the why and what's driving it and what's
driving it is the need to serve others
and that the satisfaction you and i get
and everybody all the ramsey personalize
everybody ramsay gets from helping other
people
and that's why we jump up and do a free
real estate reality check and we're
going to unpack that so we want people
calm down they're freaking out and
there's no reason for them to be scared
and let's walk through this fear
because the stinking news channels have
gotten where they're just fear porn 24
7.
their goal is just to spin you up left
spin you upright spin you up left spin
you upright got gotta get those ratings
let's see if we can get people pissed
off and mad at each other let's let's
find some reason to all be mad at each
other and that's it's just it's it's
enough
enough already
this is just crazy y'all
so uh it's the same kind of thing you
know
but avery you're doing good stuff
a bad way
so let's do the good stuff with some
peace in it and you and i'll be
high-fiving when you get your house paid
off
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today mike and valerie are in
with us in saint charles missouri and it
says on my screen you guys are debt-free
congratulations
yes we are thank you very much cool cool
cool now how much do you pay off
442 thousand dollars 793.
wow
and how long did that take
27 months
and your range of income during this
time
250 000 to 310 000.
my
my my my my what in the world do you do
for a living
well i uh do business development
sales for a construction company and
valerie i work for a healthcare company
and technology
wow careers so what kind of debt was
this 443 000
well we had a time share that i know you
love there's about nine thousand dollars
left on that a student loan of about
ninety five hundred a four one k loan it
was about seventeen thousand
uh four different credit cards that were
about 40 000 and then three different
mortgages whoa paid off the house
paid off the house
talking to weird people i love it yes
sir as weird as it gets love it love it
not a payment in the dead gum world
baby step seven way to go baby way to go
man i'm so proud of you what's this
house worth
well our main residence is about 500 000
and our lake house that we still own is
about three hundred thousand
nice
and uh how much is in retirement savings
401ks and such
between the two of us uh it's north of
one
okay so you're approaching a two million
net worth
yeah probably a little above that
i love it how old are you guys
i am 51 and i'm 42. you're like classic
classic baby steps millionaires you fit
the profile exactly and how much of this
did you inherit
uh very little there was was a little
bit towards the end there was a family
property that sold that put us over the
edge use the last 20 000 of that
um four so out of two million dollars
you inherited 20 000
yes okay so we don't want anybody to
think you became a millionaire with
inherited money yeah actually when i was
younger i did inherit a little bit more
but it was not enough to i i did a lot
of stupid with that
ah i got you okay
way to go you guys
all right what do you tell people the
secret to all this is you've really
killed it
well um paying attention to your money
uh being on the same page
and being intentional
i called your show
a couple years ago before we started
this and now you kind of inspired me and
after our conversation you said 24 to 36
months we should be at baby step seven
so i took that as a challenge and uh
finished off
the first year with 140 and then the
second
a little more than the second year got
the rest of it taken care
of so i was wrong it only took you 27
months
[Laughter]
yup
[Laughter]
you're okay with being wrong on that one
i i like it when i'm wrong like this
i'll take wrong when you're the hero
that's very well done guys so mike
valerie 27 months ago you guys were
pretty normal you were falling for a lot
of traps you were living on the credit
cards 401k loans the timeshare all these
mortgages what happened where you guys
just went we're doing this once and for
all
well it was mostly me my wife valerie is
a natural saver and i was
uh kind of a free spirit nerd on certain
items and i you know was kind of the
king of the credit card shuffle feeling
like i was doing something
and yeah and uh it wasn't working and i
actually had inherited a zero turn mower
from our family that i was supposed to
sell when the family sold the farm and
it sat under a shed for five years and
deteriorated and i told a buddy that's a
mechanic hey fix this so i can sell it
but don't spend too much money and when
i got the bill it just kind of made me
sick to my stomach and thought how am i
going to pay for this and
valerie and i weren't on the same page
with money and you know i was trying to
figure it out and
i found your program and i just started
selling everything i could to pay for
the repairs on that mower and then when
i did this debt snowball on a
spreadsheet
it made me sick to my stomach to look at
how much money we were blowing and
wasting on all the stupid wow
way to go man
way to go how does it feel valerie to be
free
and it feels pretty good
i'll take that i guess so a 2 million
net worth and not a debt in the world
absolutely amazing 51 and 40 something
years old way to go y'all way to go we
are free and uh it feels fantastic
what's the next big thing you're gonna
do to celebrate
well upgrading vehicles we just bought
valerie a new used vehicle and probably
in the next year or two i'm going to do
the same and uh might be a vacation or
two in the next year so
looking forward to just not being friend
not on anybody anything that works for
me what'd you buy valerie
uh a nissan armada oh nice car cool very
cool that's a great car
all right guys very very proud of you
are the kiddos involved they know what's
going on
yeah they don't know all the numbers uh
per se but uh i
we'd driven to florida a couple times
and listened to some of your books on
the way and the kids
had to listen to it as well so they uh
they are on board and they
they like the plan and uh
they they know that we're finally to
baby step seven they asked questions
along the way and uh we didn't give them
specifics but we kind of told them where
we're at and what we're doing and why
we're doing it so yeah it's been a
pretty good journey way to go y'all way
to go i'm so proud of you you set
yourself up
so you're 51 when you're 58 if you don't
do anything else you have 4 million
and when you're 65 if you don't do
anything else you'll have 8 million
yeah and of course you're going to do
more so
when you hit 65 you're gonna have 10 to
20 million dollars somewhere in there so
my last prediction i missed i'll
probably miss this one too but that
one's going to be pretty close so yeah i
hope so and we're you know maxing out
everything so
we're on our way yeah way to go guys
absolutely incredible all right we've
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you you're already there you are one
and a copy of uh the total money
makeover you can give that away and help
somebody out with it and a one-year uh
subscription to the membership on
financial peace university and get you
some guys signed up for that to go back
to it or send somebody through it it's
all the brand new videos they just came
out the best version of fpu we've ever
done so good stuff all right mike and
valerie st charles at missouri 443 000
paid off in 27 months making 250 to 310
they knocked it out house and everything
baby steps millionaires count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two one we're debt-free
[Music]
that's how it's done boys and girls
that's how it's done
debt-free with a bunch of zeroes on the
end love it love it well here's the
thing
the baby steps millionaire's book this
is why we did the book
because we're talking to people like
mike and valerie almost every day
and uh after having done this show for
now uh 30 years
as a matter of fact this weekend will be
30 years oh wow congratulations speaking
incredible june 25th was the date we
went on the air and it'll be 30 years on
the 25th
and so um
you know all these years of doing it
what we're running into is people like
him that you know i talked to you 10
years ago i talked to you 15 years ago
uh my dad mom talked to you 10 years ago
15 years ago i was a little kid you know
we get those calls we get those
debt-free screams but what ends up
happening is that when you follow these
steps
it is the shortest right way to become
wealthy and that's why you know that's
why we plug people into financial peace
university because a lot of these people
that have become baby steps millionaires
are following the baby steps through
financial peace university they're
learning about insurance they're
learning about why spending from you and
the new lesson with you and dr john
and when you follow these proven steps
and we tell people you know we always
have told people it takes a decade
you know to work through them most of
the time
and you know but then your baby steps
millionaire it's pretty cool
that's how you become an overnight
success over a really long period of
time
that is how it's done over a lot of
nights
but it can be done and it's slow you
wake up and you go oh my gosh we're
millionaires i love it just look up one
day go look at that two million dollars
who would have thinking
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today hebrews 13 7
remember your leaders who spoke the word
of god to you consider the outcome of
their way of life
and imitate their faith
brian tracy said leadership is the
ability to get extraordinary achievement
from ordinary
people
well brian's right and by the way most
of us are ordinary
until we
do something extra ordinary
then maybe you're not ordinary anymore
after that who knows all right dez is
with us dez is in philadelphia hi dez
welcome to the ramsay show
tell us scare me sure what's up
um so um thank you for taking my call uh
i'm
uh i'm dead i'm 24 years old and i have
about thirty two thousand dollars in
debt from various things uh ten thousand
dollars in credit cards um i have
six
sixty five hundred dollars and a
personal loan
two car loans uh that hold up to fifteen
thousand nine thousand for one car and
five thousand for another car why do you
have two cars
um
so
i uh uh i really like cars lot so i
bought a uh 2004
subaru wrx and
anyway it blew up the day i bought it
it's a long story but i got the second
guard because that car blew up twice in
a year
and i was like this isn't this is
too much right now and it got really
expensive for gas and everything
so it actually cost me less money
to
get another car
um
instead of just driving a car constantly
that's one way to justify it okay
yeah so um the goal was to sell it but
anyway i i i don't
it's blonde right now i have another
engine for it so i'm gonna put the
engine inside it and then sell it and
once i put the engine inside it but
so
anyway
my question is though
i start school this summer
i'm going to school for nursing
and
uh
i want to consolidate all my
all of my debt into a s
into a 25 000 school loan and the reason
why i want to do that because i want to
pay it off faster uh
if
from what i understand if i do that
instead of me having all these different
these different loans all over the place
because
like my one loan it has a higher
interest rate and the other one has
higher interest rates and so on and so
forth as well totality all insurance
smaller loans listen to me buddy but the
problem isn't that you have too many
debts all over the place the problem is
dez
you're the common denominator for all of
these debts so moving them into one
thing over here and moving you're not
actually doing anything i want you to
change the way you live your life
not change where your debt is moving to
yeah are you ready to do that is the
question because if not
no you shouldn't consolidate the debt
and put it into a school loan you should
pay off the debts from smallest to
largest regardless of the interest rate
and stop making bad decisions
what was the 6500 personal loan for
oh um
i had well it started off like small i
had to pull out a small loan
um
to do like various projects
i thought i was going to my credit what
is a various what is a various project
oh so like i buy and sell like random
things uh and i make profit off of it so
but anyway i was doing uh um
uh i think i was i bought a car
and i was building a race car yeah so
what do you what are you do you have a
job now
yeah i do what do you make
um
my yearly income is between 40 and 60.
but it ranges uh it could be it could be
30 one year it could be 60 other year
but i don't always know all right let me
let me tell you what i'm hearing okay
and then you you can do with that what
you will
um what we know is that debt
consolidation
loans which is what you're wanting to
use a student loan for
uh 80 88 of the time that's nine out of
10 times if someone takes out a debt
consolidation loan
they end up further in debt
and the reason is
what george was saying that you didn't
change the habits that put you in debt
in the first place let's go down your
list of debts
ten thousand dollars worth of credit
card debt buying crap you couldn't
afford
6 500 worth of personal loans i buy and
sell some stuff and i make a profit bull
crap if you made a profit you wouldn't
have 6 500 worth of debt you'd have 65
000 cash in the bank you're a con artist
yourself
yeah okay
and
i like cars ones that blow up often
so everything on the list is dez doing
something stupid
everything on your list and so george is
exactly right and i'm not saying dez is
stupid because i think you're a whole
lot like me i'm that guy man i like
doing deals i like trying to figure
something out i like my feet moving and
trading something and buying something
we used to call it horse trading when i
was a young guy because back then there
might have been a horse involved but now
there's not right so but nowadays anyway
the bottom line is you you just like
going moving things around and you're
very energetic and you're very bright
and you see things and the problem with
guys like you and me is we think we can
out earn our stupidity
yeah
and you just you know everything you
listed there looks like something i
would have done when i was your age
and so that's why i can pick on you okay
i'm not picking on you i'm picking on
what you did there's a difference i
think you're very bright
but i but i think you've made i think
you've messed up on some wisdom issues
here and going and moving the loans so
you can act like all this crap didn't
happen and keep doing the same behavior
that's a nightmare man don't do that
so it's time for dez to look in the
mirror and go wait a minute
i need to learn some lessons from every
one of these deaths so they never grow
back and then i wouldn't work my butt
off and pay off these debts as fast as i
can using the debt snowball cut up all
the credit cards get on a budget work
like a crazy man
and let's clean this debt up get rid of
that subaru and start selling everything
in sight let's take six jobs and let's
work our way through these debts as fast
as you can you can do this because
you're not a dumb guy
but boy have you done some dumb stuff
and i know that because i've done dumber
stuff and that's how i can see it and so
i'm not not picking on you like anymore
and i'd pick on myself or i'd pick on
george because i love you and i want you
to go win des that's what it amounts to
but dude
you can't just move the dead over there
and keep on with the same stupid butt
behavior you're gonna make another mess
and you're gonna double the size of your
mess so no you don't use a student loan
for debt consolidation
by the way america that ought to be
illegal
you and i are funding that crap
because your congress are idiots
why in the world we have a student loan
program that allows something like that
to even be a question
because they'll happily take your idea
of student loans is to go to college
people
and yet it's perfectly legal what he is
proposing there's nothing illegal or
immoral about it but for america to have
this as a policy while the goobers in
the white house are talking about
forgiving student loan debt and this is
where the student loan debt comes from
you ought to have your butts kicked
america because you ain't kicked your
congress's butt
unbelievable
this is exactly what's going on
so it's you know
but junior deserves a great college
experience dave how are they going to
pay for the water slide how are we going
to pay for the subaru engine
you know which is that that'll change
your collegiate activity
you know that you know let's what i get
a degree in blown subaru
that's my degree
you know it's just you know so that
that's the problem y'all and so dez i
love you man but you got to change what
you've been doing and that'll fix your
problem not borrow you can't borrow your
way out of debt and you can't out earn
your stupidity i've tried both
and i did it with a lot more zeros on
the end and i could tell you stories
that make you cry how stupid dave ramsey
was
and so that's the old saying where does
wisdom come from comes from experience
where's experience come from
yeah
stupid that's for experience one way to
get it yeah and you just don't do it
again that's i've done so much stupid
stuff george
my only goal is not to quit doing stupid
stuff but it's quit doing the same
stupid stuff
i just don't want to do the same one are
you finding new stupid stuff every year
i find something new wow that's gross
that is growth it's encouragement it's
encouragement but yeah but it's not i'm
better
because i got a whole bunch of stuff i
don't do anymore that's stupid so that
that does insulate we're all thankful
because we can avoid it when you tell us
yeah well it's um i
mean i can feel his pain i feel it
because i that's so harsh though to
actually look and go
oh this is a symptom of an underlying
problem um it's not really it's easier
to go oh this next project is going to
be it i can just make this deal happen
man that's it oh man that's that's the
disease right there
oh man
thanks to austin ben zach andrew and
kelly and james in the booth i am dave
ramsey that's george campbell we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the prince of
peace christ jesus
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you